HOW MUCH STORAGE CAN'T LOOK LIKE
WHITNEY OLSON FROM THE OLD
SUPERMAN MOVIE.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT HE LOOKED
A LITTLE BIT MORE LIKE LESSON
ESSMAN.
A BESPECTACLED LESSON ESSMAN
FROM WK RP IN CINCINNATI.
>> WELL WHOMEVER HE LOOKED LIKE,
HE DRANK A LOT OF WATER, LAURA.
FISH ARE NOT EVEN THIS HYDRATED.
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING --
>> Laura: WHAT IS THIS WITH A
WATER BOTTLE?
>> IT'S LIKE A MEDICAL SIZE
WATER TOWER.
A WATER SILO.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS PRODUCTION AT
THE HEARING WAS A BIT WANTING.
>> AMBASSADOR TAYLOR, I'D LIKE
YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
I WILL READ IT FOR YOU.
IT'S IN RESPONSE TO A
QUESTION -- >> AND HE WENT ON TO
READ IT.
WHEN YOU PLAN A BIG DRAMATIC
MOMENT, MAKE SURE THE VIDEO
LOADED.
AND ADAM SCHIFF HAD HIS OWN
EMBARRASSING MOMENT, WHEN
RELEASED A PHONIC CHALLENGE THE
WAY HE EMBELLISHED THE
PRESIDENT'S CALL AT THE FIRST
YEAR.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN I ASK UNANIMOUS
CONSENT ENTER INTO THE RECORD
THE TRANSCRIPT FROM THE JULY 25
CALL BETWEEN TRIP
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
YOU YOURSELF MR. PRESIDENT HAVE
MISCHARACTERIZED THE CALL.
>> GENTLEWOMAN WILL SUSPEND.
>> HE HAS A VERY PRIGGISH
PRESENTATION.
DOES HE NOT?
WHAT WERE THOSE CAT EYES?
>> CONGRESSWOMAN VAL DEMINGS HAD
A DRAMATIC LINE OF QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF THE HEARING.
AND, WHEN THEY ENTER THIS
IRREGULAR CHANNEL, HIGHLY
IRREGULAR CHANNEL OF THE U.S.
POLICYMAKING.
>> CAN I GET AN ENUNCIATION
GUIDE FOR THAT?
>> THERE YOU ARE THINKING ON
THEIR FEET.
>> AND APPARENTLY CONGRESSWOMAN
JACKIE STEERE WAS SO FRAZZLED
TODAY, SHE STARTED MISPLACING
OFFICE SUPPLIES IN HER HAIR.
IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY, THERE IS A
PAPER CLIP HANGING FROM HER HAI
HAIR.
AND THERE IS A DOSSIER THE BANG
BANGS.
THAT'S CONGRESSMAN SWALWELL
UNDER THERE.
THAT WAS TENSE AND DRAMATIC.
A PET THERAPY ORGANIZATION
CALLED PET PARTNERS TEAMED UP
WITH THE JOINT ADVISORY COUNCIL
TO PROVIDE THERAPY DOGS AT THE
CAPITOL.
THE VARIOUS MEMBERS WANTED TO
PET THE THERAPY DOGS TO
DE-STRESS.
MY QUESTION IS, WHERE DID THE
DOGS GO TO DE-STRESS FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE?
OR WHY DON'T WE LOOSE THE
THERAPY DOGS ON SOME OF THESE
NUMBERS IN CONGRESS.
I THINK WE COULD GET A QUORUM
FOR THAT.
>> Laura: IT'S WILL RELEASE
THE HOUNDS?
>> RELEASED THE THERAPY HOMES.
>> Laura: RELEASED THE HOUNDS.
THOSE ARE THE CUTEST THINGS WE
SAW ALL DAY UP THERE ON THE
CAPITAL.
>> WELL, SHE COULD PROTECT
YOURSELF WITH A PAPER CLIP IN